bienvenue à cette autre édition d'
espace autochtones en direct je
m'appelle anne-marie yvon merci de nous
retrouver pour notre quatrième et
dernière émission spéciale sur les
élections alors allez me dire les
élections c'est terminé oui mais cette
semaine mercredi on a connu le nouveau
gouvernement trudeau
pour nous en parler en studio un nouvel
analyste en fait il est là aujourd'hui
avec nous si by flamands y lévis ce chef
au conseil des attikameks de manouane
bienvenue si big où et quoi grand
plaisir de vous avoir sur notre plateau
un habitué alexis wawanoloath qui a déjà
fait de la politique comme on l'a déjà
dit n'est ce pas et il conseille de
bombes à odanak et comme député
d'abitibi est pour le parti où n'importe
quand tout est dit et puis nous allons
rejoindre cindy world elle est
maintenant consultant pour l'assemblée
des premières nations du québec et du
labrador cindy ne pouvait pas être en
studio avec nous mais aller à montréal
pas très loin bonjour cindy quoi et
cindy bonjour à tous exactement pour un
cours que vous donnez pendant toute la
fin de semaine c'est ça ben oui c'est un
cours sur quoi exactement rapidement là
on est curieux et plus qu'un pigripi et
gouvernance où il ya beaucoup de choses
à apprendre dans tous ces domaines là
mais on va pas en parler aujourd'hui
cindy ce sera peut-être pour une
prochaine fois on va plutôt évidemment
aller à la rencontre des ministres qui
ont maintenant les portefeuilles
autochtone dont une qui demeure carolyn
bennett
alors pour elle ça ne change pas et puis
seamus o'regan lui est parti on va
pouvoir parler du un petit peu plus tard
mais un nouveau venu marc merlin et puis
en un troisième aussi qu'ils rentrent
dans la ligue
c'est monsieur daniel vandal c'est un
métis de l'ouest du pays
alors avant pour commencer je voulais
vous demander est ce que vous êtes
content de ces nominations
on commence par 6 me tient à côté de moi
bah c'est quand même intéressant que
carolyn bennett on retrouve ce porte
ministériel oui pour les cendres qu'elle
s'intéresse ans pour pouvoir continuer
son processus de réconciliation avec ses
dix principes son approche aussi kit est
quand même intéressant pour les
communautés pour les conseils de base
des organismes notamment
oui alexis ouais ben je pense qu'on va
donner la chance au coureur ou de
nouveaux venus me suis mis là je pense
qu'il est vraiment rude à une bonne
connaissance des dossiers autochtones sa
volonté d'apprendre le monde le ghanéen
gaga et où si parlante on peut penser
qu'il ya cette sensibilité là pour être
à ce poste le pour monsieur vandal
j'espère que ce sera paul autochtone de
services du cabinet parce que c'est le
seul autochtone au sein du cabinet et le
gérei été nommé gérant des territoires
du nord-ouest dépit des les auteurs du
toit ont fait des routes une oeuvre et
du yukon
donc je suis c'est d'avoir une influence
puis de prendre sa place au cabinet
qu'en allemagne et à la table c'est
important parce qu'on sait que c'est là
que les décisions se passe pour qui est
ce qu'il madame bennett
ben moi je pense que oui a tellement eu
un travail peu d'engagements pris que le
stade livré la marchandise parce que des
engagements des belles promesses et
ennuyeux hamas de fait le gouvernement à
l'heure dans le courtant qu'il ait un
qui lui est attribué on devrait faire en
sorte qu'ils devraient voir que la
marchandise est libre et oui et cindy de
votre côté ap - pour monsieur mais là je
pense que c'est une belle ouverture la
culture juste en étant séoul après on a
là là là langlois qui fait foi
je passais bien oui d'accord si bijoux
interrompu vous alliez dire c'est sûr
que c'est un gouvernement minoritaire il
peut rester lors de moi
un an et demi oui comme s'il ya des
anges qui viennent
oui exactement deux mois peut-être pas
ils risquent d'être là un petit peu plus
longtemps que ça mais c'est vrai qu'il a
une date de péremption qui pourrait être
plus courte que la première fois c'est
pour ça qu'on s'attend à ce qu'il y ait
des marchandises qui sont livrés
rapidement seul peut aussi qu'est ce qui
arriva avec gouvernement minoritaire on
s'en est vraiment passé les
gouvernements sont plus près c'est
d'essayer de régler des dossiers pour
pouvoir dire qu'ils y ont respecté leur
langage mer donc pas tant que ça pour
être favorable justement dans ce
contexte vous le disiez maintenant il
faut livrer la marchandise c'est un peu
aussi le message qu'a voulu livrer
ghislain picard de chef de l'assemblée
des premières nations du jeu là bravo
madame si exactement l'apn aussi on a
dit bon ben voilà maintenant arrêter
nous faire des promesses de dire oui on
va le faire fait le point alors qu'est
ce qu'ils doivent faire
par quoi ils doivent commencer qu'est-ce
qui est le plus urgent sur la liste qui
a peut-être déjà été commencé qu'on doit
terminer ou alors qu'on doit
entreprendre la rapidement bien répondre
aux demandes dans les communautés parce
que cris une crise des logements une
sorte population d'aller goûter les
logements évidemment est un peu il peut
avoir trois quatre familles par maison
oui ce qui est c'est un problème qui
perdure depuis très longtemps que ce
soit dans les communautés des premières
nations ou chez les inuits aussi pour
qui c'est un problème extrêmement grave
donc ça prend l'engagement du
gouvernement donc il faut kg surtout
service autochtone canada oui pour
pouvoir répondre aux demandes
oui beaucoup beaucoup de sujets 60 ans
qui très important les enfin le tribunal
des droits de la personne du du canada
au fait donner un jugement le
gouvernement trudeau dire est allé en
appel de ce jugement
c'est une aberration on doit on se doit
de mettre en place la loi comme les
attikameks au dessus mais mélanie
initiative par rapport à la protection
de la jeunesse la prise en charge de
leurs services sociaux donc des
initiatives comme ce doivent être
poussées doivent on doit avoir un plan
de mise en oeuvre de cette loi
par rapport à la protection de l'enfance
dont on doit dire qui on veut compenser
sur le qui ont été discriminées oui on
doit pas aller en appel de france que le
ministre la justice a quelque chose de
l'eau de très important a parlé de nos
soeurs autochtone qui sont assassinées
ou disparues je pourrais parler de
justice par rapport à la nature
présentation dans les tribunaux je
préfère les de la sortie d' avec le
principe de john holmes je voulais
parler de la culture avec neuf sont en
perdition t on à quelqu'un ici qui a eu
la chance d'avoir pour agrandir dans sa
langue ou pire pas été aussi coloniser
d'autres nations ou que des tickets mais
qui prend ta qui est vivante et
l'environnement avec les changements
climatiques donc on la table à l'ardoisé
plainte pour ce qu' on n'a pas besoin de
nouvelles promesses on a besoin
universel qui ont été faites oui alors
cindy on vous voit pas toujours donc là
vous allez devoir nous dire de temps en
temps on you je veux parler moi aussi
donc là pour l'instant je vous donne la
parole
oui ben a fait messieurs mais leur
beaucoup d'eau aussi sur la planche
j'attendais donc avec la n est en fait
pas ses mots doux on s'attend à voir le
niveau l'encadrement
c'est sûr que les logements demeure une
priorité je lisais dans le 75 % des
logements de rédiger adéquat oui mais à
ce niveau là le wolof pour madame
pénètre la déclaration oui alors vous
parliez de s3 c'est évidemment décide
clarifier la le statut des femmes
autochtones
est-ce que vous avez déjà entendu marc
mireuil s'exprimer à ce sujet la whammy
non non non non personnellement non
c'est juste que je regardais le dernier
plan ministériel est ce qu'ils sont
arrivés avec la nouvelle est demandeur
qui j'espère va continuer on va
des drapeaux mais avec ce qui s'est
passé dans la dernière année
donc je vais tout de suite une précisé à
aux gens qui nous écoutent actuellement
si vous avez des questions à poser à nos
trois analyses faites le maintenant
parce que vous allez voir le temps ronde
très très vite
donc si vous avez des questions précises
sur ces nouveaux ministres et sur ce que
nos invités en pense donc avoir leurré
actions faites le maintenant écrivait
nouveau vos questions et puis nous
allons pouvoir leur transmettra au cours
des prochaines minutes
alors madame bennett elle c'est une
continuité pour elle je pense qu'en
général les critiques ont été bonnes
autant du côté de l'apn que de la pnq l
on était relativement satisfait de voir
monsieur mireuil s'installer même s'il y
en a qui se sont posé la question
pourquoi lui pourquoi c'est lui pourquoi
c'est lui exactement votre avis mais ce
que c'est suffisant de se parler moanda
d'apprendre une langue autochtone je
peux vraiment dire moi je connais pas
personnellement mais ce mail
cette expérience lui a montré ce qu'est
ce qui a fait parce que où est sa place
dans le monde
oui donc si par cette expérience
d'apprendre aux oies qui apprend aussi
des principes de la loi de la grande
paix qui comme la façon la grande loi ou
des mots h
je pense que on peut comprendre on peut
s'attendre de luidia qu'à une
sensibilité dans mardi n'est pas la
première nation envers les peuples
autochtones
donc il part avec leur même préjugé
favorable
cindy à jeudi mais dit je pense que ç'a
pris position à se rapprocher des
peuples autochtones notamment
d'apprenants une des langues
c'est positif je pense que c'est
vraiment une bonne méthode ça crée des
liens évidemment avec la communauté mois
dans ce cas ci il est venu avec des
personnes parce que on l'a entendu il ya
cru une heure par jour est le langage
donc je pense aussi à moi ce qui me veut
plus et l'efficience de son sang il
ajouté
créé à l'aéroport l'alarmé donc si je
pense que c'est de bonne augure
maintenant et moi non plus je connais
pas personnellement oui c'est juste
juste revenu soit éléments qui revenait
souvent dans les médias on sait où on
dit que c'est le premier à boire fait un
discours en langue autochtone quand le
maire de lattes injuste et je pense
qu'il y en a qui ne s'est pas le premier
mais aussi à nager bien sûr vous faut se
dire c'est le premier de production oui
c'est vrai exact mais maintenant c'est
le premier nom autochtone alors j'ai
donc dans une grange est très important
je savais que les choses au contexte
oui cindy ya madame payet drôle de
surprise aussi on s'y attendait pas en
fait
l'avez vous entendu oui bonjour ouais il
parlait quoi va mal je ne comprenais
bien c'est vrai oui d'accord parce
qu'elle a commencé à suivre des cours où
je savoure lui a préparé pour son disque
les paraphes il ya un autre élément
aussi que qu'il certifie que j'ai vu il
ya aujourd'hui c'est le comité du
cabinet sur la réconciliation
donc on en haut mais on n'a pas tout la
composition de ce comité là mais on a
emmené au met la présidente et la vice
présidente
la président de ce comité là c'est
madame cordes cloud car lac de pareloup
donc c'est la ministre de l'emploi
je pense qu'un homme et sept ministres
le président du comité sur la
réconciliation d'hommes point de vue sur
quel type de réconciliation ce
gouvernement là on est encore dans les
cada mais qu'on est encore dans les
opportunités
pour pouvoir développer nos ressources
parce que ça se retrouvait aussi dans la
plateforme libérale et la vice président
de ce comité le sait la ministre des
pêches et océans et de la garde côtière
madame jordan puis un autre chose que
j'ai trouvé particulière par rapport à
ces changements ministériels c'est au
royaume l'ancien ministre des affaires
et services aux autochtones
donc une fois qu'on le devienne appris à
gérer les interrompt l'art au ministère
de la colonisation au ministère des
ressources naturelles
il n'a pas été là longtemps posé
symboliquement sur cette nomination mais
bon on voit une nomination qui peut
déranger parce que c'est peut-être un
peu de cynisme de ma particulier qu'est
ce que vous en pensez sine die ben en
fait ce matin à l'image de cette femme
et de boer a perdu 9 mai par rapport à
ce que alexis avance je suis de
conférences et je suis désolé mais après
il va avoir des dossiers importants
évidemment en belgique au niveau
politique toi mais oui oh oui pour
monsieur vandal mai mais pour ce qui est
de la norme de la nomination de monsieur
origone de l'avoir déplacée le service
aux autochtones aux soyons clairs alexis
qu'il l'a fait la nation de pl est au
bout de cette saison
à tout le moins il va avoir des bonnes
dispositions envers les peuples
autochtones fille qui vont peut-être
avoir cette ouverture d'esprit là
j'espère que ça va être quand c'était
parce que c'est quand même très
important pour nous d les peuples
autochtones le territoire ses points
forts du sel de notre philosophie
journal
donc toutes les questions il va voir
jerry le pari plaindre d'avoir à gérer
beaucoup d'éléments qui ont qui nous
touche directement la protection de
l'eau oh mon dieu oui ça c'est un
dossier crucial en fête est aussi
l'approvisionnement d'eau dans les
communautés mais là ce sera pas son
dossier à lui en 2011 sa marque mary
c'est un gros dossier aussi que mark
miller comment communauté puis on l'a vu
en eux mêmes des communautés ou en lots
qui passe ou ébullition mais qui manque
d'eau je pense pas qu'il rende dans les
statistiques
il est au bloc sanitaire pour alice
laver puis aller chercher leur route
parce que l'eau dépasse ainsi contaminés
au marketing en libye aussi exactement
et là en fait il faut faire vite dans ce
dossier la halle les promesses sont
toujours dit oui on va arriver d'ici
2021 ou 2022 ce sera réglé
mais on est encore loin du compte et on
voit que il ya des communautés qui
finalement obtiennent de l'eau potable
et d'autres communautés pendant salle
aquila perdent ou qu'ils qui ne l'ont
plus aussi facilement comme la semaine
dernière à man on a eu beaucoup de
problèmes avec l'accès à l'eau potable
donc il ya eu des bris puis a fallu
fermer l'accès pendant quelques temps
mais ça s'est réglé quand même assez et
toute la communauté a été privé de 1 300
communautés et à ce moment là qui vient
faire les réparations qui se dépêchent
de se pointer ceux des personnes qui ont
été formées dans la commune cris qui ont
pu faire les réparations mais il faut
dire que les comme on appelle ce au
deuxième pour les usines de filtration
filtration d'eau de riz doit être à
refaire
évidemment ok pour les besoins de la
communauté bien puce on a deux parties
du village
oui mais est-ce que c'est dans les plans
c'est pas dans les plans mais évidemment
c'est ça va être en discussion
prochainement et avec qui vous aviez en
discuter alors avec marc meyer mc mais
le évidemment est-ce que vous avez déjà
des rencontres de prévues d'ailleurs
avec lui les uns ou les autres sine die
en tant que consultant pour la pnq elle
est ce que vous allez avoir une
rencontre avec lui au niveau de la
grande conche prépa vous le préciser
mais je sais que des jeux à l'heure
actuelle donc et sony contraction déjà
été dit oui
et du côté de la pn tu elle est ce qu'on
a déjà un agenda bien précis et on c'est
sûr d'en quête vers quels dossiers le
pister dès le départ
absolument absolument on commence par
quoi la déclaration de monsieur ski
logement le la région dont on parlait
plutôt de la décision qui était reçu par
les deux personnes il ya aussi tout ce
qui bouge et là c'est 92 en janvier
l'application donc oui non on est déjà
comme vraiment établie les prieurs hind
ahmas et ça va donner commune et dans
une petite communauté comme manouane
lorsqu'on met sur papier les les plus
grands enjeux né à traiter rapidement ça
serait quoi du logement sociaux c'est ça
on y revient encore qu'ils essaient
vraiment la priorité à ma main c'est les
logements sociaux il de chemin de
manawan qui est quand même un chemin
forestier qui assez dangereux mais qu'on
y passe quand même assez souvent
oui mais ça l'est aussi pour les deux
autres communautés camec là alors
normalement lorsque vous allez vers les
ministres et pour essayer de régler des
dossiers ce que vous mettez ensemble les
trois communautés avec constant awashish
en tête pour aller régler ces dossiers
là on travaille plus avec
ben le grand chef constant au haschich
on travaille plus sur les négociations
sur la reconnaissance des droits sur sur
un système d'intervention des autorités
disent qu'un mec et que les questions
d'infrastructures n'ont ainsi plus les
communautés chacune doit prendre son
temps oui alors seulement c'est pas
évident et c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que
le chemin de manawan il est encore
encore un chemin forestier c'est pas
pour changer demain matin c'est pas pour
changer demain matin mais il ya des
projets qui s'en viennent mélicie de
ceux là réfection la réfection des
routes qui vont rester stables pendant
quelques années mais après qu'est ce qui
va se passer
oui moi c'est pas évident non plus à
main alors alexis on parlait tout à
l'heure vous pariez de on parlait de là
comment ça s'appelle la déclaration
universelle des droits des peuples les
droits des peuples autochtones
normalement c'est un dossier qui va
tomber dans les mines qui bat carolyn
bennett on est carrément dans les
relations
entre la coupe et il y nations
autochtones
donc je pense que si un des dossiers qui
devraient prioriser parce que de ça va
découler quand même mal mais le reste si
on respecte la déclaration universelle
des droits des peuples autochtones
on va respecter nos droits face aux
territoires si on ne ressent en place
mais on la respecte cette déclaration
dont vont respecter nos droits face à
l'allant face à face à nos capacités de
prendre nos décisions
donc c'est ça deviendrait quasiment
quelque chose de
dépendamment du statut qu'on veut il
donner par un parent quel type de lois
qu'on veut lui donner mais ça prouve
qu'ils manqueront un statut quasi
constitutionnel un peu comme on le voit
avec la charte des droits et libertés du
québec après un statut qui avons
construit une heure parce qu'elle peut
inscrire dans la constitution mais est
interprété par les tribunaux comme quasi
constitutionnel donc très très très
importante
je pense que ce n'est peut-être statut
comme ça qu'on devra dire chercher pour
cette déclaration pour la mettre dans
des noues loi canadienne proclamation
obala éventuellement moi je pense que
l'idéal ça serait leur font du canada ou
de boue ont pris place et les des
peuples autochtones à titre d'acteur et
non de sujets fédéraux mais ça veut
faire partie de ma dernière chronique et
je donnerai des correspondances aux
facteurs d'accord alors cindy je vous
tends la parole parce que là je c'est
difficile de savoir quand vous voulez
intervenir ou pas donc est ce que vous
vouliez ajouter quelque chose
non ma fille et moi je me questionne jeu
le projet de loi de monsieur saganash
démarre au feuilleton est comme si les
visites qu'ils ont un peu devancé au
niveau provincial
comment ça il est rare de voir le jeu
capable en ce moment je suis allé voir
qu'est-ce qui pourrait proposer on parle
du projet de loi que justement qui avait
mis sur la table roméo saganash mais
romeo n'est plus là pour poursuivre sa
mission mais je pense qu'il va y avoir
des gens qui vont prendre sa place vous
est dans l'opposition il ya quand même
des personnes intéressantes mais d'un
molson dry blood qui va être là oui ok
est indépendante mais il reste que la
fuite qu'elle a été réélu c'est un
symbole fort et elle va avoir une
tribune elle veut continuer à voir une
tribune elle va pouvoir continuer à
suivre les
les faits et gestes du gouvernement je
pense qu'on n'a pas grand chose à
attendre des conservateurs par rapport
aux affaires autochtones pour la défense
de nos droits donc je peux vous mis
beaucoup d'attention à rechercher mais
si on va voir la pression npd madame k 4
excusez-moi la prononciation c'est pas
exact et madame guérison sont quand même
des personnes qui est une personne qui
est professeur et des militants qui sont
là qui sont qui ont deux voies qui vont
avoir une tribune qui vont être capables
aussi de construire parce qu'il ya de la
critique
mais qu'est ce qu'il faut savoir de dans
les gouvernements c'est qu'on fonctionne
aussi beaucoup en comité parlementaire
puis c'est là que la majorité du travail
parlementaire ce fait on le voit pas
parce que c'est pas des chicanes parce
que c'est pas bon pour les médias mais
c'est là que le gros du travail peut se
faire dans des négociations dans l'ajout
l'amendement aux lois donc que vont
pouvoir avoir des places quand même
assez importante
le puits par rapport à quai ce qui est
du bloc québécois ben madame bérubé qui
est la député d'abitibi baie james
nunavik eeyou engagé l'ancien attaché
politique la remorque saganash dans son
équipe
donc qui à le démontrer ce jusqu'à ce
qu'est ce que j'ai pu voir une belle
ouverture une belle conscientisation
face aux enjeux autochtones qui de plus
chez que dans le parti et des députés
comme sébastien de mire madame guigou
comme un supplément de où le chef qui
sont très sensibles aux enjeux
autochtones qui veulent parler il va la
bonne relation de nation à nation donc
je pense qu'on va pouvoir voir ce que de
la part du npd et du bloc une bonne
opposition pour bien surveillé pour que
les enjeux autochtones soit livrée comme
on l'a dit un peu plus tôt et le fait
que le parti au pouvoir s est
minoritaire ça leur donne une chance
encore plus grande de pouvoir s'exprimer
d'amener leurs points aussi je dois être
plus chaud ou par ces deux oppositions
maintenant du côté des conservateurs
il ya quand même quelques autochtones
qui ont été élus ce dans le parti
conservateur qu'est ce qu'ils peuvent
amener comme contrepoids ces gens là
la plupart sont dans l'ouest
oui qu'est ce que les autochtones chine
parce qu'ils étaient quand même
plusieurs cantons avaient regardé la
liste des gens qui se présentaient dans
les différents partis chez les
conservateurs il y avait aussi quelques
autochtones
la plupart étaient dans l'ouest du pays
mais il était là bien présent ben comme
de parti conservateur agit plus sûres
comme un mec c'est sûr que les députés
autochtone qui ont gagné ils vont
vouloir aider pour le développement des
communautés autochtones mais à quel
niveau on dénie dans cet internement en
terre britannique où la ligne de parti
est très importante et cette ligne de
parti n'est déterminé par le chef
on peut avoir la pression influences
qu'on est au conseil des ministres dans
des parties comme la bd où on a des
candidats qui sont autochtones et qui
sont qui peuvent être très beau court
par rapport à l' opinion par rapport à
la question ça va être en concordance
avec la ligne de parti donc vont pouvoir
agir là dessus mais dans les faits les
conservateurs on remet un chef qui en
débat a dit on veut aider les
communautés autochtones qui disent oui
ou développement donc comme si biladi
savons rester dans le cadre économique
puis je pense pas qu'on ait grand chose
à s'attendre ce coin du globe du le
manque d'ouverture la sphère de la part
des conservateurs c'est quand même un
comble à qui le projet de loi sur la
déclaration universelle des droits des
peuples autochtones
oui oui exact donc j'ai pas le temps
d'attendre que ça cindy le même avis ce
qui m'a mené lundi par rapport à la
déclaration soutenue
d'où le blocage est survenu dans sa
femme j'ai pas d'attendre comme comme ça
qu'on appelle dans les émissions
précédentes
j'ai invité mark miller a participé à
des missions la semaine prochaine pour
l'instant je n'ai pas sa réponse
mais on pourrait déjà réfléchir si vous
étiez avec moi ou sur le plateau qu'est
ce que vous voudriez savoir qu'est ce
que vous lui demanderiez ses cinq
premiers de l'oci qui assure sa table
c'est cinq priorités ni logement encore
si pizzi jolivet l'ex-amant je les ai
vus dans beaucoup de communautés
c'est tellement centrale l'histoire des
logements parce que ça dézingue pas
qu'après sauce les capacités des jeunes
à l'école sur la sorte d'église toutes
les infections comme la grippe les flux
toutes ces choses ne peuvent rester chez
les inuits la tuberculose qui est causé
par justement ces lieux là où on se
retrouve un de là plusieurs grande
promiscuité en famille et pour la mieux
développer leur communauté leur économie
familiale
oui il ya quelques logements qui sont en
construction d'ailleurs en ce moment à
man one on l'a vu avec un avec bones
plusieurs nouvelles au cours des
derniers des derniers mois mais ce n'est
toujours pas suffisant c'est pas
suffisant c'est c'est juste quelques
petites poussières d'un besoin des
logements sociaux
je me rappelle que je travaille à
lac-simon il y avait 300 par exemple
besoin était de 300 plus du double qu'en
mai
à quoi ça ressemble chez vous en ce
moment similaires comme par exemple pour
340 maisons présentement il ya 250 mans
à huy donc c'est pas 2 trop petit
pincement faire des changements si d'une
belle bonne chose note que ça arrive
conformer
john's atikamekw enfin mais ça prend des
investissements considérables juste pour
rattraper le nouveau cd solutions qui
existent depuis longtemps de vue avec le
rapport sur les peuples autochtones y
accorde quel honneur sans délai avec des
investissements historiques
bon le gouvernement trudeau à faire des
annonces d'investissements mais on tend
devait voir atterrir dans les
communautés
c'est plus ça bloque dans les eaux près
des fonctions c'est ce qui l'incombé
niant de la réconciliation du helmand
mais on devrait parler des colonisations
à la dragon sillage de renault ze
bulgarie 12 lits alors quand on parle de
décolonisation en fait si monsieur
miller était là ce que vous lui
parleriez de décolonisation avant tout
oui parce que je trouve qu'on utilise le
thème réconciliation comme un instrument
de communication jusque dans ses plus
bas la réconciliation c'est plus
al'avantage de l'état et non les
autochtones oui cindy si mark miller
était la lgv ou lui demanderiez quoi de
votre côté bienfaits de son propre aveu
le ce que j'ai lu ce monsieur mais leur
ce qu'ils considéraient que la relation
d'égal à égal avec existait un peu le
gouvernement les prospecteurs auparavant
et fait gagner donc je d'égal à égal
mais c'est sûr que tous les logements
c'est parfait pour moi ça fait des
produits aussi et j'espère dans laquelle
de 5 que les clio magnifique logement
126 pour les premières nations
donc soit il peut pas faire fi des
ressources et le premier aussi avec lui
par rapport à la déclaration
mais il ya aussi poursuivre avec
l'application donne des recommandations
avec des appels à naxos de la commission
vie et de l'aisne faveur par rapport à
l'aspect défunt
l'association des femmes aussi sont des
femmes mais moi oui on parlait de la
commission vient on parlait aussi dans
quelle nation assure les femmes et des
filles autochtones assassiné disparu
c'est encore un dossier que que madame
bien maintenant pas madame milan mais
madame bennett a entre les mains
il ya eu des promesses qui ont été
faites en juin dernier on disait oui ok
on va finalement mettre en place des
mesures concrètes
est ce que vous y croyez le gouvernement
à l'époque évidemment on était sur le
point de se lancer en élection
maintenant que le gouvernement libéral
est de retour est ce que vous y croyez
il faudra attendre le discours du trône
pour un suivi du sujet et pion de répète
on va voir ce salon les actions qui vont
être mises en mots voir ceci sur la
terre et on voit que nos salles sont les
protéger puis sow ben on va pouvoir
avoir un jugement là dessus je pense
dans un an ou deux ce qui est encore
long est ce qui est encore long mais bon
il va des choses comme ça les actions
des jeux que ion le plein est pas mise
en place et la d'action il peut déjà mis
en place ont dit ok on a un plan
d'action va le mettre en place on fait
juste parler de lemaitre des changements
comme ça pour qu'on plus être capable
d'évaluer de faire des études qu'il faut
que ça c'est pas à court terme on est
capable
si vraiment qu'est ce qu'ils y ont pris
quatre actions va avoir un impact dans
la vie des gens tout à l'heure vous
parliez de daniel vandal comme
l'indienne service est-ce que c'est pas
nécessaire quand même qu'ils aient un
autochtone qui se retrouvent dans des
dossiers autochtones où je crois que
c'est un porteur puisque c'est une bonne
chose qu'il ya un autochtone auto la
table mais après ça est ce que monsieur
vandal c'est quoi son expérience est ce
qu'il va se laisser encore driver se
laisser pâturer dansereau le moi je vais
vous dire sincèrement dans ma ville et
rodin diem services de jeunes service
cailly mi-temps face je prenais pas ce
que chamakh
le 62ème voir oui mais c'est ça bon je
me contenterai pas contente pas juste
d'être le bon indien service
je rage et j'étais capable de le dire
nettement moins sa table dit que les
choses n'étaient pas correctes ou si je
me contait contentez pas tous bien
paraître juste une belle plante verte
puis ce qu'est ce que j'espère que
monsieur vandal va avoir la force et
courage de faire est ce que vous le
connaissez un peu autour de la table
personne ne le connaît non donc ça va à
lui de faire ses preuves n'étaient
boxeur oui bon on sait jamais alors va
peut-être prendre les gants de boxe et
se mesurer à justin trudeau
parce que lui aussi est un boxeur et si
justin trudeau n'est pas suffisamment à
l'écouté des besoins des gens du nord
alors on aborde rappeler les sujets du
nord parce que je pense qu tourne à
table on n'a pas d'expert sur les enjeux
inuit
à moins que vous auriez quelque chose à
dire à ce sujet là l'élection d'une des
plus doués dans la circonscription du
nunavik boîte quand même quelque chose
d'important voir être une voix forte où
as repos [ __ ] par sa ligne de parti
parce que je pense que sa ligne de parti
correspond à ses opinions correspond à
casque avait eu à mener donc avoir quand
même une belle liberté dans l'expression
de quesques aveux pour
ce qui peut arriver par des lignes de
parti quand on est député puis elle je
pense que la position où aller a va
pouvoir avoir la place pour s'exprimer
puis je trouve que c'est un bon modèle
sont belles belles belles candidates une
belle personne qui est là qui jouent
vraiment de la loire a dit comment il
s'appelle déjà
je fais oui c'est ça exactement
enfin on sent que elle veut prendre ses
dossiers en main puis elle veut les
mener à terme la au delà je pourrais pas
m'exprimer plus que sinon non mais c'est
ça non non non ok on va revenir sur ouï
oui cindy je vous vois lever le doigt
non en fait je les cheveux que monsieur
vandal et si besoin est criant
mais ces changements climatiques on le
sait dénoncée par les devis je pense
qu'il vaut pro avec deux supports
oui c'est intéressant parce que j'ai
rencontrés hier chila watt cloutier qui
a été une femme politique du nord mais
qui ne fait plus de la politique qui
n'est pas une militante écologiste non
plus ne veut pas qu'on le voit comme ça
mais c'est une femme qui est extrêmement
impliqué en fait c'est son inquiétude
c'était justement ça ce ne sont pas les
politiques qui peuvent changer la donne
ce sont les citoyens des citoyens comme
elle qui le crie sur tous les toits à
travers le monde et on le voit avec son
son ouvrage qui a été traduit en
français l'accès aux gros froid n'ont le
droit au froid c'est ça exactement
et puis disons juste ce qu il a dit oui
oui absolument et qui disait il faut qu'
il faut que ce soit il faut que ce soit
les citoyens qui se battent pour changer
les choses parce que elle même sa
crainte c'est que ça ne viendrait jamais
des politiques là donc c'est au cours de
cet automne des démarches des luttes
mais est ce que ce gouvernement va
répondre aux changements climatiques est
ce qu'ils vont faire
un projet neo des verts quelque chose
demain parce qu'on a mis quelqu'un qui
vient de l'ouest à l'environnement pour
pour faire part à l'alberta monsieur
guilbeault qui était le champion de
l'environnement qui rendu au patrimoine
wii va avoir son mot à dire mais bon il
ya beaucoup de gens qui ont pris ça
comme un mauvais signal envoyé par
rapport à la volonté réelle est ce que
c'est juste une volonté de paradou c'est
une vraie volonté du gouvernement de
s'attaquer aux changements climatiques
est ce que on est qu est-ce qu on aurait
pu mettre un ancien militant ça aurait
peut-être piège pour lui ben je donnerai
aussi cet outil dangereux l'homme et il
reste qu nommer quelqu'un qui vient de
l'ouest pour cette position là je pense
que c'est un message pour qui veut que
monsieur va falloir qu'il joue à
l'équilibriste les intérêts climatique
de tout le monde
il les a et eric onomique de l'alberta
de la saskatchewan qui sont vos espoirs
là on le disait en ouverture on ne sait
pas pendant combien de temps ce
gouvernement sera au pouvoir
des moines des années enfin ça y est il
ya un an
comme on dit une fenêtre de quatre ans
et évidemment la fenêtre peut se
refermer à n'importe quel moment
mais qu'est ce que vous espérez donc
pour les prochains mois absolument en
sybille je pense que c'est ce que je
vous écoute
ben je sais que il ya eu le mouvement
dans no more en 2013 oui ça fait déjà 10
ans pis si ce gouvernement répond pas
aux demandes des communautés autochtones
ce qui va avoir un nouveau sur une
nouvelle soulève mme autochtone en plus
on sait que présentement l'amérique du
sud il ya un soulèvement autochtone qui
est la même
importante puis je crois qu'ici aussi ça
va arriver un moment donné je
m'attendais pas à ce que vous dites ça
alexis je pense que la déclaration de
verser des droits des peuples
autochtones ça serait bien qu'on les
sauve vite pour qu'on puisse à présent
inspiré que les autres éléments
législatifs cool de cette déclaration là
je pense que ça se paye le cas quand
même quelque chose d'important bien
grâce à bombay les besoins dans huit ou
les jours de l'osce et la dignité
humaine de pouvoir en avoir avoir l'âge
main pour refaire de dignité humaine
avoir le droit de vivre parce qu'on est
une femme c'est de quelque chose qui
venait de la dignité humaine donc je
pense que les éléments de base relève la
dignité humaine devrait plutôt fait ça
exactement régler les besoins de base 1
et cindy des gestes concrets
c'est ce concept en étant un
gouvernement minoritaire le temps coule
déjà partis dans ta vie donc ça se paie
une continuité mais beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus conquérir tout si je
faisais la déclaration comme alexis pour
moins d'une importance capitale parce
que de là découle la naissance appelée
niveau des doigts et le logement alors
finalement on demande un gouvernement de
continuité mais un gouvernement qui va
agir concrètement sur les promesses qui
avait déjà été fait
voilà merci à tous les trois merci
d'avoir participé à cette émission alors
cindy world de boncourt 1 vous êtes à
l'école nationale d'administration
publique à montréal
je vous laisse retourner à vos élèves à
vos étudiants merci merci see by flamand
je vous laisse reprendre la route vers
man one vous êtes descendus ce matin
exprès pour nous vous retournez à man
wan ce soir bonne route soyez prudents
sur le chemin forestier
en attendant qu'il soit sera le thé
merci beaucoup et alexis morano lohan
bonne continuation aux lyonnais et merci
à vous tous pour cette autre édition d'
espace autochtone en direct alors
j'attends la réponse de marc berdoll le
nouveau ministre des services aux
autochtones et nous auront peut-être la
chance et le plaisir de la voir sur ce
plateau la semaine prochaine
je vous y attends vous aussi merci
beaucoup
oh
[Musique]